un territoire entre ruralité et zones
urbaines la 10e circonscription recouvre
le sud-est du département des yvelines
de ville de près de vingt mille
habitants en rambouillet et maurepas et
plusieurs communes rurales entouré de
village comme montfort l'amaury ou
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines au coeur des
enjeux sur ce territoire l'agriculture
avec plus de 50 % de surfaces agricoles
cultivées les attentes sont importantes
sur ce secteur dominé par l'activité
céréalières et maraîchères
autre thématique dominante la ruralité
lors du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle dans cette
circonscription
emmanuel macron est arrivé en tête avec
27 89% des voix talonnée par françois
fillon
avec 27% des suffrages arrive ensuite
jean luc mélenchon et marine le pen à 15
% et 14 % député sortant jean-frédéric
poisson se présente sous les couleurs du
parti chrétien-démocrate investi par les
républicains il veut accéder à une
troisième législature avec la volonté de
poursuivre son travail dans le domaine
de la lutte contre le terrorisme
face à lui la candidate de la république
en marche aurore bergé conseillère
communautaire à saint quentin en
yvelines
ex-membre du parti des républicains elle
a rallié emmanuel macron pendant la
campagne présidentielle
elle s'engage notamment sur les
thématiques de l'égalité homme-femme du
progressisme et de l'union européenne
en embuscade face à ce duel annoncé
benjamin nicoletta sous la bannière de
la france insoumise
il doit faire face à la division de la
gauche le maire socialiste de
saint-arnoult jean claude husson corinne
auribeau pour le pcf ou encore l'élu
rambolitains l'écologiste david jutier
autres divisions du côté front national
françois le hôte devra faire face à
philippe chevrier président du parti du
front libérés ils soutiennent tous les
deux une position souverainiste et
protectionniste dans le domaine
économique et sociétal au total les
électeurs auront le choix parmi cette
liste de quatorze candidats sur une
circonscription ancrée à droite depuis
excepté en 2010 lors d'une élection
législative partielle qui avait vu la
victoire de l'écologiste anny poursinoff
face à jean frédéric poisson
plus de 88 mille électeurs sont appelés
aux urnes ce dimanche 11 juin